mais avec nous pour en parler nicolas
vidal éditorialistes marcel bénézet
président de la branche des cafés bars
et brasseries du syndicat ni jean
christophe qu'elle met ce vice président
du syndicat mg france médecins
généralistes également bonsoir à tous
les troy murphy messieurs d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france donc a
priori un réouverture des terrasses à
l'animé à marcel bénézet ce que c'est un
bon début où vous espériez plus
aujourd'hui nous avons une date déjà non
d'espérer le 15 d'un acquis par du 17 on
sait pas trop mais déjà on a une date
est ce qu'elle sera tenu je l'espère
parce qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes plus
gouverné par les politiques mais par le
virus qui peut de jour au lendemain sur
paris bon aujourd'hui si vous la
situation a l'air de s'améliorer mais ça
restait quand même difficile dans les
hôpitaux tout ça donc bien sûr on veut y
croire et on espère qu'on va réouvrir
nos terrasses des le dès le 15 mai bien
sûr alors justement on va jeter un oeil
un petit peu plus en détail sur ces
chiffres on va les voir s'afficher l
antenne ce fameux taux d'incidence en
france 1 353 en moyenne 4 sur une
semaine pour 100000 habitants je vous
laisse regarder le détail avec tout de
même un l'île de france qui est passé
brillant que ça 556 cas sur une semaine
pour 100000 habitants on voit clairement
des disparités on va enchaîner
si vous le voulez bien avec ce chiffre
journalier déco vide 1,34 1968 nouveau 4
kovy dans 24 heures plus de 2000
nouvelles hospitalisations et plus de
cinq mille neuf cent cinquante patients
en réanimation
ce ne sont pas des chiffres brillants
n'est ce pas docteur qu'elle metz les
chiffres quand vous les voyez vous en
tant que médecin ces chiffres là est ce
qui vous permettent d'envisager le
déconfinement prévue à la mi
mais par le gouvernement on était
inquiet quand on voit ces chiffres on
est inquiet parce qu'ils correspondent
effectivement le porte parole a dit on à
une décrue lente et plus lente que prévu
de décontamination parce que le mariage
gay est extrêmement contagieux et on
sait par ailleurs qu'elles variant
brésilien aussi qui est là qui ne se
développe pas parce que lorient monde et
prendre toute la place et on sait pas
très bien ce qui va se passer alors si
vous demandez aux médecins que je suis
si les échéances gouvernementales vont
être tenues je suis bien en peine pour
répondre parce que vraiment on ne sait
pas ce que va faire l'épidémie et c'est
le problème de cette épidémie c'est que
depuis le début on court après mais
c'est très difficile de dire on va des
comptines à telle date on va ouvrir des
bars alors en même temps le gouvernement
et c'est pour ça qu'il est là prend ses
décisions en fonction d'autres critères
que les critères médicaux qui sont les
critères économiques et des critères
sociaux je comprends tout à fait que le
représentant des des restaurants qui est
avec nous et très envie de revoir les
terrasses ouvrir et je comprends tout à
fait que les gens aussi est très envie
de sortir mais on a ce virus qui est là
qu il a été très présent donner une
vaccination qui avance mais qui avance
un peu trop doucement est vraiment le
sujet aujourd'hui c'est la vaccination
en fait tout ce qu'on peut sur le
terrain pour vacciner nos hôpitaux sont
saturés je crois que c'est ça le critère
c'est le taux d'occupation des lits de
réanimation
on fait tout pour éviter que tout
n'explose et donc on est dans cet
équilibre précaire entre la chaîne des
du confinement et des le taux
d'occupation des lits de réanimation qui
est la vaccination sur le terrain c'est
cet équilibre là qui est difficile à
trouver c'est pour ça que prédire
aujourd'hui qu'on va absolument réouvrir
début et ça me paraît faire preuve d'un
grand optimisme
moi franchement je sais pas ce qui va se
passer début mai en tout cas nous
gouvernement semble vouloir tenir ses
promesses nicolas vidal quand on entend
le docteur qu'elle mais c'est quand on
entend le porte parole du gouvernement
on se dit que la décision d' emmanuel
macron elle sera forcément politique le
docteur nous disait basée sur des
critères économiques et sociaux mais
enfin aussi sur du politique on rappelle
que dans un an il ya la présidentielle
emmanuel macron est en quelque sorte
acculé à produire de bons résultats à
satisfaire des français vous apportez un
décryptage politique effectivement
j'entends ce que dit le docteur est la
raison il ya une situation préoccupante
et si la décision d' emmanuel macron qui
est compliqué aujourd'hui je pense qu'il
est dans une impasse emmanuel macron
parce que il a annoncé cette date du 15
mai et très sincèrement c'était beaucoup
trop présomptueux mais pourquoi il a
annoncé et on l'a déjà dit sur le
plateau
finalement il est des réseaux sociaux il
ya aussi l'idée sociale de ceux de se
caser mais les gens n'en peuvent plus
les gens dit dans une camisole
sanitaires on comprend que l'épidémie
l'épidémie est encore très hot dans les
chiffres c'est un coin sud mais les gens
n'en peuvent plus aujourd'hui et
emmanuel macron il s'est tellement
avancé sur le 15 mai aujourd'hui comment
voulez vous qu'ils reculent pour moi
très sincèrement il à 1.2 c 4 sociale
dans les mains emmanuel macron il a
décidé de fermer il va décider de
rouvrir ou pas d'ailleurs vous voyez il
ya des espoirs des espoirs qui sont un
peu douchés on a tous envie bien entendu
de reprendre une vie normale mais
emmanuel macron il s'est mis dans une
situation très dangereuse on nous a dit
qu'il y avait des talents maintenant
d'épidémiologistes mais on va voir
effectivement le 15 mai s'il va pas être
obligé de reculer emmanuel macron hélas
il recule qu'est ce qu'il se passe
est-ce que les gens on va accepter
effectivement de rester encore un mois
ou deux semaines trois semaines dans une
camisole sanitaires ça c'est la vraie
question est très sincèrement j'aimerais
pas être à la place d'emmanuel macway je
pense je le redis qui s'est beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup avancé manuel mâcon là
dessus marcel bénézet vous on disait à
vous représenter les cafés les bars et
les brasseries quel est l'état d'esprit
de la profession parce que pour
l'instant on vous a entendu ici ou là
mais mais pas tant que ça il n'y a pas
eu une vraie révolte aujourd'hui
clairement vous attendez que le
gouvernement tienne ses promesses ou
quoi qu'il en coûte sur le plan
sanitaire vous seriez prêt
éventuellement à accepter un autre délai
ou ou pas du tout c'est pas dans l'état
d'esprit
aujourd'hui je pense que la pole à la
profession n'en peut plus mais je pense
aussi que la société n'en peut plus
comme le disais tout à l'heure notre
intervenant
les gens sont sous une camisole ils n'en
peuvent plus aujourd'hui on a deux on a
trois problèmes
on a le problème de l'épidémie qui est
important on a le problème économique
être aussi important maintenant un
problème psychologique
en duo une psychologue et l'homme
aujourd'hui vous avez des gens qui sont
au bord de la dépression
comment on va ressortir de cette
situation de kobe on va sortir c'est que
ce soit la population des commerçants
bien sûr avec des crédits qui n'en
peuvent plus avec avec des
remboursements qui peuvent pas assumer
aujourd'hui la situation est très
compliquée
je vous assure que ne sait pas qu'on va
sortir de ces deux mais cette date du 15
mai on y tient bien sûr qu'on dit il
parce que ça va tu le bouffer c'est une
et une bouée jetés à la mer
on va tâcher lucky accroché voilà donc
ms quand vous entendez famille qui
représentant les les cafés les
brasseries les restaurants vous ça vous
fait peur en tant que docteur où vous
vous dis bon c'est pas la pire des
situations les terrasses ouvertes on a
vu qu'en espagne a priori ça provoquait
pas non plus de deux catastrophes les
restaurants en plein air oui tout
dépendre des mesures de distanciation
qui sont faites on peut penser
effectivement qu'en plein air
il y avait une distance respecter ça
pour éviter les contaminations mais ces
études là sont faites avec une épidémie
qu'on connaît un virus qu'on connaît les
russes bouge lui et le 6 minutes on a vu
que le biais de lorient getty plus
contagieux que le variant précédent on
sait pas ce que feront les autres rien
parce qu'il y en aura d'autres
il faut pas se leurrer et donc
franchement je moi je peux pas dire ça
je mais je comprends tout à fait je
souhaite les restaurateurs je peux vous
dire que effectivement ils sont détresse
mais il ya beaucoup de gens des 13 ans
pays et donc on est face à un choix
politique comme l'a dit notre
intervenant politique qui est de choisir
voilà on choisit entre le sanitaire
l'économique le social c'est le show qui
est extrêmement difficile
si vous me demandez mon avis de médecin
je vous dirais qu'on verra le début et
pour voir où on en est et on décidera en
fonction mais ya pas que le critère
médicale et six à tout problème du
gouvernement il n'y a pas que les
critères médicale
nicolas vidal est ce que ce n'est pas
pire de prendre la décision de déconfit
nez et de tenir en l'occurrence des
promesses peut-être intenable sur le
plan sanitaire et d'être là on imagine
le pire vous parlez tous deux de marion
qui font peur d'être obligé de
reconfirmer ensuite ce serait pire que
tout bien entendu sur c'est pire que
tout sur la question qu'il faut se poser
vous regardez emmanuel macron la même
de quoi qu'il en coûte la question c'est
qui ça va coûter à qui ça va coûter
effectivement soit de continuer à faire
du confinement ou ne s'est pas une
liberté régulier ce curieux concept de
la liberté régulier de la liberté
encadrée ou sk qui ça va coûter sur le
plan sanitaire
c'est toute la question aujourd'hui mais
la réalité ouvrir ce pays c'est que les
gens n'ont que je lui répète des gens
n'en peuvent absolument plus on imaginer
restaurateurs les cafetiers les
commerces sont essentiels ce beau mot de
commerce sont essentielles et
aujourd'hui je le redis emmanuel macron
il ya un mur face à lui il obligé de
choisir et là on est vraiment dans le
choix politique et il sait très bien
emmanuel macron bien entendu que il
risque d'avoir une explosion sociale
et ça je crois qu'il a la conscience
aujourd'hui et c'est pour ça qu'il est
maintenant obligé de donner une
perspective la perspective à titre
individuel ou à titre collectif c'est
absolument important et vous vous pouvez
pas un moment donné entraver la liberté
des gens permanent je parle de camisoles
sanitaires même s'il ya des recours sur
l'épidémie bien entendu il ya des
risques
on est tous d'accord on est tous
conscients de ça mais à un moment donné
on peut pas enfermer un pays comme ça
vous avez les bars exemple faire mieux
qu'une série de gens comme ça
après moi je suis pas médecin c'est pas
mon boulot moi c'est mon un décryptage
politique
emmanuel m'apprend il ce soit dans une
situation il vous l'avez dit stéphanie
il ya effectivement la présidentielle
qui dans un an et ça va nous coûter très
cher emmanuel macron quoi qu'il en coûte
cette présidentielle mais vous savez
finalement lieu en même temps il a
beaucoup limité aujourd'hui c'est plus
le temps du en même temps il faudra
choisir
il va falloir trancher et gouverner
c'est choisir alors le nerf de la guerre
évidemment le sait c'est la vaccination
pour le moment pas d'autre issue qui
semble crédible
regardez ces chiffres au 21 avril 1 19%
de la population seulement à en france
qui a reçu au moins une dose soit de 12
millions et demi de personnes 4 millions
ennemis un peu plus 1 68 million de
personnes ont reçu deux doses docteur
c'est c'est pas brillant on affiche ces
chiffres comme une communication
quotidiennement fin par rapport au
royaume uni et en israël
on est vraiment dans les fraises si
j'ose dire familièrement emmanuel macron
ça le met forcément dans une impasse
parce que quand boris johnson nous
annonçait enfin l'a annoncé et au
royaume uni un calendrier c'était qu'il
y avait un succès à côté d'un de la
campagne de vaccination c'est pas notre
cas alors c'est pas tout à fait vrai ces
mêmes c'est un peu faux nez dans le
peloton on est on est moyen va dire on
est dans la moyenne européenne pour la
vaccination
bon ils ne sont pas loin de la moyenne
non plus parce que quand il annonce les
chiffres de lens en fait ils précisent
pas que si c'est une 2 2
et lorsqu'on compare la vaccination à
une dose dans ce cas soit coni pas si
mal alors on vaccine à tour de bras
n'est pas assez vite je suis bien
d'accord
il ne faudrait plus de vaccins bon c'est
un problème mondial c'est un problème
européen en particulier et c'est aussi
un problème lié à l'astra l'astra
aujourd'hui pour le mois de pour le mois
d'avril c'est 500 mille doses pour le
mois de mai c'est un million trois cent
mille doses de prévu et on sait qu'il ya
une désaffection de l'astra qui nous
pose problème parce que dans le même
temps donc si les gens ne seront pas
vaccinés avec d'astrazeneca alors
l'astra zeneca je comprends pas ce qui
s'est passé un très honnêtement c'est
donc en vaccins adénovirus qui est très
décrié en france lorsqu'on regarde les
chiffres
lorsqu'on parle de façon très simple il
ya eu dans le monde sur l'astra 469
thrombose et 191 en europe ce qui est un
chiffre normal par rapport aux thrombose
qui serait une façon naturelle entre on
n'y a pas plus de thrombose dans la
population qui ne se vaccinent pas que
dans la population qui se vaccinent par
contre on a eu quelques accidents
exceptionnel 18 cas avec des accidents
très graves thrombose cérébrale ce qu'on
appelle c'est l'idée donc pas les
détails mais ce sont des choses très
très grave
donc on a eu 25 sur d'un million de
vaccins autrement dit un cas par million
si on relativise ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que vous avez à peu près les
mêmes chances de mourir à cause
astrazeneca que su nous faire foudroyer
en marchant dans les rues de votre ville
voilà il faut quand même relativiser
donc ya pas de sur risque avec astra je
pense qu'il faut le redire
mais on constate une désaffection
d'astra il faut en tenir compte et donc
il faut augmenter la production de
vaccins à arn donc les files heures et
les modernes on va augmenter cette
production et en particulier va
augmenter à partir du mois d'août et
septembre alors les doses progresser
très vite mais c'est déjà un peu tard
moi j'aimerais que en plus de signer
beaucoup plus vite beaucoup plus vite
parce que la solution quand une fois
elle est dans la vaccination est la
solution je crains tu pas de le dire
elle est aussi dans ce fameux passeport
vaccinale qu'on nous promet alors il ya
des gens qui crient à la privation de
liberté franchement c'est pas parce
qu'on va sortir notre application
découvrir notre papier disant qu'on est
bien vaccinés pour aller au cinéma que
si une atteinte intolérable à la liberté
il faut arrêter de dire des bêtises moi
aussi ça me permet d'aller au cinéma ou
des les bords en coin terrasse ou dans
un restaurant
j'aurais bien content d'avoir mon
attestation qui cohabitent donc mc
sinovac sixième accident mais pour ça il
faut que nous ayons bellows on va en
parler dans quelques instants avec notre
ami brasseur à monsieur bénézet sur ce
passeport sanitaire voir s'il est
d'accord mais avant tout sur l'astra
zeneca je voudrais vous faire écouter
justement emmanuel macron qui est bien
conscient enceinte de cette désaffection
des difficultés pour convaincre malgré
tous nos citoyens sur l'astra zeneca qui
est une problématique à laquelle là on
doit collectivement réfléchir en termes
de communication et de capacité à
convaincre
alors nicolas vidal la communication sur
astrazeneca nos confrères du figaro nous
murmure que jean castex a même suggéré
que sheila se fassent vacciner pour
inciter des plus de 55 ans voilà en
france qui douteraient de l'astra zé
meka savoir en dit long sur la
communication petit peu laborieuse du
gouvernement vous avez vu mon rictus
stéphanie vous avez vu mon rictus et
comme jean-michel bancaire qui
aujourd'hui j'aurai à la marelle et il
faisait pierre caillou ciseaux dans une
école au centre de loisirs c'est pareil
ils n'ont plus que la communication
c'est absolument terrible cette histoire
là la réalité cette histoire de
vaccination convaincu pour ou contre
c'est qu'on a prêté allégeance à l'union
européenne pour ce produit pour produire
finalement pour les acheter il bout
comme jet la becquée vaccinale bien
entendu même en terme de logistique a
énormément de problèmes alors on nous
dit en permanence oui ça va accélérer sa
vague c
ça va accélérer mais les semaines
passent les mois passent si ça
n'accélère pas c'est ça la réalité
médicale également en hiver n'en avoir
gêné il faut communiquer pour comble
qu'on est d'accord c'est ce que nous
disait le docteur calmès on ad astra
zeneca des doses qu'on jette par
centaines tous les soirs en france parce
que il ya une défiance on a mal
communiqué c'est aussi la responsabilité
du gouvernement
alors peut-être battu mais moi je pense
aussi une liberté individuelle à se
faire vacciner ou pas ça c'est
extrêmement important on peut pas
forcément obligé les gens sur vacciner
après si le gouvernement veut
communiquer là dessus qu'ils
communiquent très bien pour lui mais je
crois qu'au moment donné il ya une
liberté à se faire vacciner ou pas alors
qu'on peut parler du pass and literature
mais moi je n'appelle la liberté de
chacun de se faire vacciner ne pas se
faire vacciner me semble-t-il c'est un
droit absolu il ya individuel à chacun
voilà ce que je peux répondre vraiment
cette idée là si le gouvernement
communiqué aujourd'hui il ne fait que
communiquer gouvernement marcel bénézet
justement sur cette question du passé ni
terre le docteur nous disait voilà c'est
très bien si ça peut nous permettre de
retourner au restaurant au cinéma vous
en tant que représentant des brasseurs
des cafetiers quelle est votre opinion
alors nous tous qui sera bon pour faire
revivre les gens normalement on est
preneur
même moi je suis vacciné astrazeneca et
je suis pas marié mais encore là il est
devant vous mais non tout ce qui sera
bon pour pour faire pour favoriser la la
clientèle à revenir chez nous on le fera
si moi j'ai envie d'aller au cinéma j'ai
sorti de moins bons moments passés
veille sanitaire
non nous tous qui ce qui est bon à
prendre le prend pour que les gens
puissent ressortir en toutes celles
tranquillité et en toute sécurité
nous on est preneurs de tout ça donc on
veut retrouver sa liberté et nos clients
aussi nous attendrons ils sont ils sont
ravis de le retrouver
docteur qu'elle metz il ya évidemment
vous en avait parlé
7ce danger ce spectre des variants est
ce que c'est
c'est ce sujet qui va tout faire capoter
selon vous la question des variants
brésil
et on voit que la france a pris les
mêmes restrictions concernant le variant
indien ça suffira à stopper ces
dangereux variant il va falloir
s'habituer à vivre avec le co vide
locaux vides et toutes ses formes et
tous c'est lorient qui vont se succéder
très probablement c'est pour ça qu'on a
vraiment que la vaccination pour pour se
sortir de là parce que ça va évoluer en
aura d'autres quid il est probable qu on
nous dira au mois de septembre
il faut vacciner avec le nouveau vaccin
arn qui prend en compte tel était le
variant il provoque comme la grippe
chaque année il faudra qu'on soit
vacciné je dis pas que ça va arriver
mais je dis que c'est probable cette
épidémie est maintenant une pente
d'ennemis et qui touche au nombre
incroyable de genre je vois mal comment
le s'arrêterait surtout que bon on
maxime des occidentaux parce qu'ils ont
les moyens de ces pays des vaccins mais
il doit rester les réservoirs des pays
africains des pays indiens etc qui eux
n'ont pas forcément les moyens de
l'accident la surpopulation et qu'ils
vont être des réservoirs à virus dont
nous ne faisons pas d'illusions on va
devoir vivre avec la machination et
c'est pour ça que la question de la
réouverture de l'activité économique se
pose et c'est pour ça que la question de
la vaccination ici si aiguë je veux dire
il faut vraiment qu en vacciner jean
rapidement ont retrouvé une vie normale
dans un contexte de pandémie
merci en tout cas à tous les trois
docteurs jean christophe calmel marcel
bénézet nicolas vidal d'avoir été avec
nous et d'avoir accepté ce décryptage en
direct